Derek Jeter's daddy duties have
officially begun the 43 year old former
MLB star is officially a dad Derek and
his model wife Hannah welcomed their
baby girl Bella rain on Thursday funny
enough it was Jeter's former team the
New York Yankees who actually confirmed
the news Friday morning tweeting
congrats to Derek and Hannah Jeter on
the birth of their daughter Bella Rayne
Jeter we can't wait to meet her the
gorgeous couple tied the knot in July
2016 before announcing they were
expecting their first child together in
February
et caught up with the 27 year old Sports
Illustrated model in New York that same
month she opened up about her hopes for
their kids and admitted they'd like to
have three I just want them to set their
own goals and have it nothing to do with
us because I think it's not fair it is
it's a tough thing you know when when
you have like a mom that did this or a
dad that did this so I just hope that
they don't have that people don't have
those expectations for them and that
they just do what they love and what
they're into
[Music]